est doux heureusement
vous diront Diana et sa famille aboutcha
en banlieue de Kiev c'est ironiquement
dehors près du feu convient se chauffer
moi je coche presque tous les jours
dit-elle il coupe l'électricité le plus
dur c'est le soir parce qu'il fait très
froid
quand on se retrouve entre voisine
autour des flammes c'est aussi pour se
donner du courage
c'est fatiguant mais on se sent
réchauffé par nos soldats didiana qui se
battent pour nous et nous savons que son
réchauffés parce que nous endurons sans
pleurer sur notre sort depuis l'attaque
du pont de Crimée en octobre la Russie
multiplie les salles de missiles sur les
infrastructures énergétiques civiles au
moins 8 attaques majeures on privait des
millions d'ukrainien d'électricité d'eau
et de chauffage environ 40% du réseau de
distribution électrique est endommagé il
doit être réparé un déficit qui rend
inévitable des coupures de courant
régulières
dans la région de Kiev entre 30 et 50%
des foyers sont sans électricité à un
moment ou à un autre c'est un crime de
guerre selon le directeur général d'un
important fournisseur d'électricité en
Ukraine
[Musique]
qu'il y aura d'autres dommages dit-il
mais nous sommes aussi convaincus que
nos employés vont continuer à réparer le
réseau électrique
en moins de deux mois ces employés ont
réparé plus de 1800 km de lignes
électriques le réseau parfois désuet ne
tolère pas les fluctuations constantes
alors partout à Kiev va dit mais son
équipe répondent aux appels incessants
et toujours urgent pour établir le
courant
parfois j'ai des moments de
découragement à de mes valises mais ils
sont bref je comprends que j'ai le
pouvoir de faire quelque chose et je
dois le faire parce que quand je suis à
la maison sans électricité je sais que
d'autres travaillent pour moi alors je
fais de mon mieux pour eux
pour chauffer leurs habitations la
majorité des gens ici dépendent d'un
système central dans lequel on fournit
de l'eau chaude or beaucoup de villes
ukrainiennes ne peuvent plus alimenter
le système avec de l'eau chaude et
doivent prendre la décision de drainer
les canaux pour éviter que les tuyaux
n'éclatent autrement dit pas de
chauffage de l'hiver alors que les
températures pourront atteindre les - 20
dois-je chez Diana c'est dans la cuisine
qu'on concentre les activités il y fait
plus chaud
Nikita 8 ans fait ses devoirs sous
l'oeil attentif de Nadia sa grand-mère
elle s'inquiète que l'école où il peut
enfin retourner soit encore plus froides
que la maison mais lui le remarque à
peine trop heureux de ne plus étudier en
ligne
même si c'est froid je me sens au chaud
j'ai un bon chandail et je porte une
combinaison dessous pour tremper l'ennui
et le froid on accumule les couches de
vêtements et on se cache sous la couette
sous plusieurs en fait et on se réfugie
dans le sommeil très tôt
Paulina l'arrière-grand-mère sa commode
très bien de l'inconfort après ce que
j'ai enduré pourquoi je partirai
ce qu'elle a enduré c'était l'occupation
des Russes les tirs et ses voisins tu es
de sang-froid elle dort peut-être trop
mais maintenant au moins elle le fait
sur ces deux oreilles ici Marie-Eve
Bédard Radio-Canada